Loic: I'm also video blogging Davos, and my
answer to the question is very very simple.
That's what Davos is all about.
I think what everybody should do in 2008 to
help the world make a -- become a better place
is to think outside of our box and outside
of our own current environment.
Mine is technology and I focus too much on
that, but learn about everything else happening.
So try to focus on Africa, try to on environment
on energy.
We saw all the topics discussed here, and
then bring into a global conversation and
understand what -- how we can help.
And generally what we -- our tendency is to
be too much focused on our own environment.
So, that would be my thing is to you know
open your mind and try to focus an hour or
two or more a day on something else than what
we can bring.
Like Nicholas Negroponte for example you know
creating the one laptop per child PC a few
years ago and launching it now.
That's fantastic.
So that's